you may remember the incredible story of
anthony ray hinton a man who spent
nearly 30 years on death row in alabama
for crimes he did not commit he was
released in 2015 when all charges
related to two murders were dropped
hinton turned his life story into a
best-selling book now he's out with a
young reader's version of the sun does
shine aimed at 10 to 14 year olds he
hopes his life will provide important
lessons of hope to young people ray
hinton joins us right now good morning
ray how are you doing
i'm doing fine to you good good now you
were last here in 2018 when oprah picked
your book for her book club what have
you been up to since
i've been blessed to travel around to
various state colleges and share my
story of injustice as well as trying to
find a way to uh make the justice system
more equal for everyone
we appreciate you sharing your story
with us right now but we want to share
something with you actually a video
check it out
mr hinton or should i say
dr
anthony ray hinton dr ray so proud of
you and all of the great work you're
doing and so happy to see
the sun does shine shining now for young
adults
congratulations
thank you it does shine it shines bright
just like that smile i saw a smile come
over your face dr hinton thanks to an
honorary degree what did you think of
that video how did it make you feel
it makes me feel wonderful you know uh
oprah and i
are connected uh
on honesty and love for one another and
respect for one another and i think she
is one of the most fantastically in the
world
she didn't have to do what she did for
me
since the choosing my book i'm
proud that she did and i will forever be
thankful to her
well i know
mr hinton dr hinton it's really good to
see you uh i know oprah has
oprah has deep affection for you she's
shooting in um georgia and so she took
time off the set to send you a message
but i remember when oprah invited you
and your friend lester to her house in
hawaii and you had been there maybe a
week and she said do you guys want to
stay longer you said no i got to get on
back and mow the grass
[Laughter]
which we thought was so funny because
most people think you know i'll hang out
in hawaii but he said no i gotta get on
back and the grass is growing i got to
get on back but i'm wondering you've
been out for a few years now
is it still hard for you is there are
there things you still struggle with or
things that still surprise you even now
that you're out
uh yes you know uh gail to be honest
with you uh when you spend that amount
of time
uh in a five by seven
or crime that you didn't commit or every
time the state of alabama or any other
state
or execute someone
or it comes back into play
uh what i witnessed 54 million one woman
being executed uh i have to deal with
when i do cut the grass
or i stop for whatever reason in that
same spot and i remember as though it
was yesterday
that a day that the police came and
arrested me
while you were cutting the grass wow
absolutely and
it's funny i've been home seven years
or
i lock my does i try to be home at a
certain time i'm caught up in this uh
scenario that if it happened once they
can make it happen again
uh
but i tried my best to be as
careful and make sure that i'm around
somebody that at least could give me an
alibi so wow what i'm really saying is
that he never is free um
i have to live with this uh
by myself and as i told you uh when i
first met you the state of alabama have
not even offered me uh the opportunity
to see a psychiatrist or psychology or
to talk
to talk and so
uh i have to deal with it the best way
that i can and
uh i try to smile every day i try to
build life for those that are in
darkness and i try to not think about it
but i'm going to be honest with you
every day every day i go home i live in
the same house that i was kidnapped in
and i have to uh
that price and so on
i can't complain and i will not complain
but i'm just stating the facts uh i
think somebody you know you you know mr
hinton it's just heartbreaking to still
hear how deeply affected you are by this
and really how could you not be deeply
affected but i'm always fascinated
despite all of this you say you have no
bitterness and that you always had hope
how in the world did you have no
bitterness when from the day you were
arrested mowing the grass the cops said
you're going down because you're black
the jury's white the prosecutor is white
no matter what you're going down how do
you not have bitterness and you said
alabama still has offered you nothing
absolutely well you know i have uh
from a child i realized that
i cannot afford
uh to allow the state of alabama to take
uh what joy i have um
i believe that i have to move on
i believe that
i surround myself with good people uh
i have to forgive them
it's forgiveness not about other person
as i say forgiveness is about you and
they took 30 years for me there's
nothing i can do about that but i am
determined not to give them any any of
the joy that i have and i want to live
the rest of my life whenever uh until
that day god called me i want to be a
light for people i want to be uh
inspiration for young
people that uh i see every day and talk
to every day that don't have no hope i
don't yeah and what is your message to
these young people exactly yeah what is
it were you gonna ask him tony yeah
exactly i was gonna say
mr hinton on to gayle's point what is
your message what is the one takeaway
you hope young people get from this book
i hope young people get the fact that
they have a choice to make or you can
drown in your sorry you can drown in
bitterness i have the opportunity to go
around the country
and i have to tell you you see young
people at the age of 10 11 12
that have no
hope in their life
it's heartbreaking and i think we and
the politicians more than anybody have
done a bad job in trying to make
the next generation feel uh where they
have hope to be anything they want to be
and i want them to know that
i don't think you can get any lower than
what i was on death row for a crime that
you didn't commit sitting in a solitary
confinement for 30 years
if i can have hold on to hope and come
out and try to be the person that i know
that i am inside i want them to know
that they can do the same thing and uh
you are you are the definition of not
allowing someone to dim your light
because the sun does shine we appreciate
you the young readers edition of the
sunday shine is on sale now